actions of Republican lawmakers who
continue to refuse to take action on
stronger gun laws
the president will continue to call on
Congress to take action to ban assault
weapons and high-capacity magazines
require safe storage of firearms
eliminate gun manufacturers immunity
from liability and require background
checks for all gun sales and state
officials must do the same
this has been one of the worst weeks for
of 2023 so far in terms of anti-lgbtq
bills becoming law in States Across
America Three anti-lgbtq Laws have been
enacted so far this week in Kansas
Indiana and Idaho just yesterday the
North Dakota Senate passed 10
anti-lgbtq bills in just one day a
single day record
in Kansas the state legislation overrode
Governor Kelly's veto to make Kansas the
20th state that has banned transgender
kids from participating in schools
sports
with the enactment of a new law in
Indiana 14 states have now banned gender
affirming Health Care while some of
these laws are currently blocked by
courts this is a dangerous a dangerous
attack on the rights of parents to make
the best health care decisions for their
own kids
according to the Human Rights Campaign
more than 50 percent of transgender
youth in the U.S which is estimated to
be more than 150 000 kids live in States
in which transgender youth have lost
access to or at risk of losing access to
gender affirming care
look this is awful news let's be very
clear about that
lgbtq I plus kids are resilient they are
Fierce they fight back they're not going
anywhere
and we have their back this
Administration has their back we are so
proud of the kids across this country
who have organized protest and school
walkouts to tell the politicians in
their states to stop this legislative
bullying I know that these political
attacks can really take toll on people's
mental health so I want to say directly
to lgbtqi plus kids you are loved Just
As You Are
just the way you are and if you're
feeling overwhelmed you call 988 the
national crisis hotline and dial the
number three to talk to a counselor who
has been specifically trained to support
lgbtqi plus kids this is a new service
that the Biden Administration is proud
to offer during these incredibly hard
times for these trans kids
now one last thing before we move on uh
to uh to the briefing on Sunday oh sorry
okay so the in town pool has to gather
uh for the president's departure
and we'll just continue uh so if you all
want to go ahead and do that feel free
and then we'll we'll still continue with
the briefing
uh so just so so we can go quickly here
I want to give you guys a week ahead as
we normally do on Fridays on Sunday
the president and the First Lady
let's do this quietly friends thank you
on Sunday the president and the first
lady will return to the White House from
Camp David on Monday the president and a
first lady will host the 2023 White
House Easter Egg Roll a tradition dating
back to 1878 a teacher for more than 30
years first lady Jill Biden is
continuing her theme of education for
the event transforming the South lawn
and the ellipse into a school Community
full of fun educational activities for
children of all ages to enjoy in
addition the time-honored traditions of
ruling and hunting eggs this year's
White House Easter Egg education role
will also feature a Schoolhouse activity
area reading Nook talent show field trip
to the farm picture day a physical
education Zone a snack time tent and
more on Tuesday through Friday the
president will travel to the United
Kingdom and Ireland the the president
will first travel to Belfast Northern
Ireland from April 11th through April 12
to Mark the tremendous progress since
the signing of the Belfast good
Friday agreement 25 years ago and to
underscore the Readiness of the United
States to support Northern Ireland's
vast economic potential to the benefit
of all communities
the president will then travel to
Ireland from April 12th through April
14th he will discuss our close
cooperation on the full range of shared
Global challenges he will also hold
various engagements including in Dublin
County louth and County Mayo where he
will deliver an address to celebrate the
Deep historic ties that link our
countries and people on Monday we'll
have some more to share about the
details of that trip now finally as you
as many of you know
over the past many months departments
and agency key to the Afghanistan
withdrawal have been conducting thorough
internal after Action reviews examining
their decision-making process and
execution those reviews fed into a
process looking across the
administration and today the NSC will
also be releasing a document that
provides our perspectives outlines in
Broad Strokes some of what we learned
and how we have already implemented
those lessons in other Global challenges
my colleague Admiral John Kirby is here
today to discuss that document and we
with all of you today and answer are
your questions and with that Admiral the
floor is yours
good afternoon everybody
so I want to start today by again
updating you as Karine said on the
administration's work to assess the
withdrawal from Afghanistan
as you all know over these many months
departments and agencies key to the
withdrawal conducted thorough internal
after Action reviews each of them
examining their decision-making
processes as well as how those decisions
were executed today they are making
those reviews available to relevant
committees in the Senate and in the
house as previewed by secretaries
blinken and Austin in testimony last
month
those reviews as Karine said rightly fed
into a process looking across the
administration so today we are also
making available to all of you and to
the public a document that provides our
perspectives on the withdrawal and
outlines and Broad Strokes some of what
we learned as well as how we are already
implementing some of those lessons
that document will be posted to the
White House website at the conclusion of
my briefing
but I'd like to take some time if you'll
allow me to provide you an overview
first and most critically the
president's decision to end the war in
Afghanistan was the right one
the United States had long ago
accomplished its mission to remove from
the battlefield the terrorists who
attacked us on 9 11 and to degrade the
terrorist threat to the United States
from Afghanistan
and now with that war over we can more
squarely address the most pressing
challenges of our day America is on a
stronger strategic footing more capable
to support Ukraine and to meet our
security commitments around the world as
well as the competition with China
because it is not fighting a ground war
in Afghanistan
of course we continue to address
terrorist threats which has the
president accurately assessed would had
migrated to other parts of the world
through effective Over the Horizon
operations including those that took out
the leaders of Al Qaeda and Isis
al-zawahiri and Abdullah
respectfully respectively
well while it was always the president's
intent to end that war it is also
undeniable that decisions made and the
lack of planning done by the previous
administration significantly limited
options available to him
President Biden inherited a forced
presence in Afghanistan of some 2500
troops
was the lowest since 2001.
he inherited a special immigrant Visa
program that had been starved of
resources and he inherited a deal struck
between the previous administration in
the Taliban that called for the complete
removal of all U.S troops by May of 2021
or else the Taliban which had stopped
its attacks while a deal was in place
would go back to war against the United
States
the president's transition team asked to
see plans for that removal they asked to
see plans for a security transition to
the Afghan government and they asked to
see plans to increase the processing of
special immigrant visas
none were forthcoming
transitions matter
that's the first lesson learned here
and the incoming Administration wasn't
afforded much of one
thus President Biden's Choice was Stark
either withdrawal all our forces or
resume fighting with the Taliban he
chose the former but even in so doing
secured extra time to conduct that
withdrawal stretching it out to August
and that's the second Point worth making
despite having his options curtailed
President Biden led a deliberate
rigorous and inclusive decision-making
process that was responsive to facts on
the ground
Focus keenly on the need for proper
planning in fact President Biden
directed his top National Security
leaders to begin planning for a
withdrawal even before he had made the
final decision to leave Afghanistan he
ordered troop reduction plans plans to
turn over bases and equipment to the
Afghan government as the previous
administration had negotiated plans to
draw down our diplomatic presence and
plans to evacuate both American citizens
and Afghan allies alike
indeed evacuation plan and planning
started in Spring of 2021 and the
president ordered additional military
forces pre-positioned in the region by
mid-summer in case they were ever needed
throughout President Biden insisted that
his team plan for worst case scenarios
such as the fall of coddle even though
the intelligence community's assessment
when he was making the decision in early
2021 was that Taliban advances would
accelerate only after the withdrawal of
U.S forces
the president repeatedly requested
assessments of the trajectory of the
conflict from his military and his
intelligence professionals no agency
predicted a Taliban Takeover in nine
days no agency predicted the rapid
fleeing of president ghani who had
indicated to us his intent to remain in
Afghanistan up until he departed on the
15th of August and no agency predicted
that more that the more than three
hundred thousand trained and equipped
Afghan National Security and Defense
Forces would fail to fight for their
country especially after 20 years of
American Support
in fact the assessment was that the
promotion of acting defense minister
Bismillah Khan muhammadi would actually
strengthen their resolve to stay and
fight
and so another lesson learned was the
need to plan early and extensively for
low probability high risk scenarios
I should note here that our experiences
in Afghanistan informed our decision to
set up a small group of experts for
worst case scenario planning on Ukraine
which included simulation exercises and
our ability
to forcefully and plainly speak publicly
about the risks we saw of a pending
invasion now look there's always going
to be tension between highlighting
warning signs that a country May
collapse and undermining that same
government
and that's a difficult balance to strike
but in Ukraine and before that in
Ethiopia for that matter we prioritized
earlier drawdowns of our Personnel when
each of those capitals were under threat
in fact months before Russia's Invasion
we released intelligence with trusted
partners and our warnings about the
invasion grew louder and more public
this aggressive approach allowed us to
organize with our allies and help enable
Americans in Ukraine to depart safely
and just to remind
we continue to facilitate the safe
departures of Americans from Afghanistan
when they tell us they are ready to
leave and we have proudly welcomed
nearly a hundred thousand of our Afghan
partners and their family members to the
United States
many of these families left Afghanistan
after the withdrawal and they continued
to arrive on a regular basis
now I'd be remiss here if I did not also
express our gratitude to the many
private and non-profit groups including
those comprising Veterans of the war who
helped us identify contact and arrange
for the safe transport of thousands of
these Brave Afghans without their help
or the incredible assistance we receive
from countries in Europe and the Middle
East that allowed us to use their
facilities as way stations we could not
have moved as many people as quickly as
we did
and that's yet another lesson that we
learned this one about the power of
allies partners and Friends
now we know we need more help which is
why we urge Congress to assist us in
improving the special immigrant Visa
program and by passing The Afghan
adjustment act both of which will make
it easier for us to keep meeting our
commitments to our Afghan allies
no comments none
about this withdrawal would be complete
without mention of the deadly attack on
the Abbey gate
at how many Karzai International Airport
on the 26th of August
the president at the time made it clear
to operational commanders that Force
protection remained His Highest priority
in those tense days when the threat was
particularly high he accepted the
recommendation of his National Security
team to extend the timeline for
evacuations only after his senior
military officials confirmed that they
had sufficient resources and authorities
to mitigate threats including those
threats posed by Isis king
he trusted the best Judgment of his
leaders on the ground to make all
operational decisions including with
regard to Abby gate
the president and the first lady will
always honor the sacrifices of the 13
service members who were killed in that
attack
and we will never forget their families
we will mourn with them
remember with them
and support those gold star families we
mourn as well the loss of those Afghans
killed by that suicide bomber on that
day and others who lost their lives
during the withdrawal and we will always
honor the bravery and selflessness of
every member of the military the Foreign
Service the intelligence community and
our civil service
who made possible the largest airlift
evacuation in military history and all
under the constant threat of attack
the effort was certainly not without
days of pain hardship or bloodshed but
neither was it without courage or Poise
or professionals
for all the lessons that we take away we
should remember that over 20 years of
war and in its final days these men and
women saw things and did things and
carry things with them that you and I
will never fathom
we must make sure that they and their
families know that their service
mattered we must make sure they get the
help and the support that they need
we must make sure that their legacy is
never forgotten they ended our nation's
longest war that was never going to be
an easy thing to do and as the president
himself has said it was never going to
be low grade or low risk or low cost
we should be humble enough to let that
also be a key lesson learned from
Afghanistan
thank you I'll take some questions
so John thank you for doing this but I
think I speak on behalf of my colleagues
in this room and we want the record to
reflect that this was sent to us about
10 minutes before the briefing began
with little notice and it's the very
definition of a modern major holiday
News company releasing this uh at the
beginning of the high holidays and after
months of requests from Republicans and
the broad Republic
um so why today and is this all we get
and is this a response to the studies
that were done by the agencies or is
this considered a summary
and there's a lot there
um this is the result of months and
months of work by individual agencies
who are participating in the withdrawal
to voluntarily review that withdrawal
which they did
and they worked through that
these are these documents are classified
um and we felt it was the responsible
thing to do after
those reviews were done
to then run a process across the
administration to take a look at those
reviews ourselves across the interagency
work our way through it and then provide
them to the relevant committees and
leaders on the hill which we did today
we think that was the responsible thing
to do and what you're seeing today is
the result and the culmination of an
awful lot of work Ed no effort here to
try to obfuscate or try to bury
something it's an effort to try to be as
open as transparent as we can be and
what you've got in that document there
is a a pretty fair summary of our
perspectives of the work over those many
months and pulling and collating a lot
of those Lessons Learned together and
we're trying to present certainly the
the key Lessons Learned the ones that uh
that were able to share more openly and
more publicly with you and I'll tell you
this you got questions after the
briefing today I'll stay here as long as
you want you got questions after the
briefing today you know how to get a
hold of me we'll answer whatever you
have I got two I got two specific ones
about what's in this document after
speed read here on page eight the
president received and accepted the
unanimous advice of his top National
Security officials to end the evacuation
on August 31st what is the definition of
the top National Security official
because we know for example that General
McKenzie who was then head of centcom
has said he objected to aspects of this
so what's the definition of a top
National Security official the I I am
loath to get into the individual advice
that uh individual members of the
president's team give him that would not
be appropriate for me but I can tell you
having lived through this as well at the
Pentagon that the the president
specifically asked his team
should we extend past the 31st he
specifically asked them to go back and
look and see what that would look like
because we had secured this additional
time from the Taliban to the 31st of
August and the team did that the team
did that Ed not just at the highest
levels of the Pentagon the secretary did
the chairman of the Joint Chiefs uh to
General McKenzie but even the
operational commanders on the ground and
there were numerous flag and general
officers on the ground at the airport
all of them took a fair look at the
president's request and came back to him
her name said that it would not be
advisable given the high threat
environment remember what also happened
on the 26th that attack at Abby gate and
then we had a very high temp between the
26th and the 30th in which of course
there was a kinetic strike taken in
downtown Kabul uh there was a there was
high temp and so the advice of his
senior National Security Team all the
way up to the senior levels of the
Pentagon advised him that the 31st was
the appropriate date to end that
evacuation there's four pages here of
blame on the previous administration or
this White House explanation of what the
last White House did regarding
Afghanistan nowhere in here does there
appear to be any uh expression of
accountability or mistake by either the
president himself or others
they're ready for what happened I I
would argue that the very fact that we
voluntarily
the agencies voluntarily decided to go
conduct after Action reviews nobody told
them to do that that wasn't legislated
by Congress they did that on their own
the fact that they did that and that we
were now placing it in uh in uh on the
hill for Congress to look at the fact
that we digested and distilled some of
the key points of that and gave it out
in a public document the fact that I'm
up here talking to you about it I think
shows you how seriously the president
felt about learning lessons from this
withdrawal I would also point out to you
that the work isn't over so number one
even before you got that document
some of those lessons were applied I
talked about Ethiopia I talked about
Ukraine
um and number two it's not like uh it's
not like the work is all over uh the
president signed the legislation
enabling the the Afghan war commission
to to be formed and we're going to
continue to work and cooperate with that
that's going to look at the whole 20
years uh America's longest war deserves
a lengthy review and lengthy study and
the president's committed to that
thank you in reading this you seem to be
conceding that evacuation should have
happened sooner and faster saying we now
prioritize earlier evacuations noting
that today you would message evacuations
more aggressively I understand you've
made clear the president does not have
any regrets about his decision to
withdraw but in hindsight in reading
this does the president have any regrets
about how this withdrawal was carried
out the president is very proud of the
manner in which the men and women of the
military the Foreign Service intelligent
Community I went on and on and on
conducted this conducted this uh
withdrawal but look I've been around
operations my entire life and there's
not a single one uh that uh that ever
goes perfectly according to plan
things happen sometimes enemies get a
vote
um and uh and you always want to learn
from that and one of the things that we
learned and I talked about it here in my
opening statement as well uh is that uh
you gotta that that balance of striking
when do you when do you pull out when a
government is under threat particularly
a friendly government
um
and do so in a way that doesn't
undermine the very government you're
trying to support that's a tough balance
to strike and it's different in every
single case and as I said we learned
from Afghanistan and we applied that
lesson in Ukraine and Ethiopia that
being aggressive in the information
space and being willing to move a little
sooner may be the best thing but does he
wish he had done things differently the
president I think everything is laid out
here in this document about uh the made
the main takeaways the main lessons that
we learned and again the president's
enormously proud of the men and women
who conducted this withdrawal and just
one last thing on the last page here you
note that the speed and ease with which
the Taliban took control of Afghanistan
suggests that there was no scenario
except a permanent and significantly
expanded U.S military presence that
would have changed the trajectory I
wonder what is your message to the
veterans to the families of the Fallen
who may read that and wonder what was
the point
the president said uh many times that uh
the mission that we originally were sent
in to Afghanistan for was accomplished a
long long time ago remember they were
ordered in under President Bush to
avenge the 9 11 attacks and to go
specifically after Osama Bin Laden and
Al-Qaeda and decimating and degrading Al
qaeda's capability in Afghanistan was a
mission that we accomplished a long long
time ago and over time the president has
talked about this uh the mission in
Afghanistan morphed into something it
wasn't intended to originally be that
doesn't just because the mission changed
over time under previous administrations
and Leadership and scenarios doesn't
mean that anybody who served in
Afghanistan doesn't have something to be
proud of doesn't have
sorry doesn't have
service to this country that they can
take with them the rest of their lives
and feel honorable about it
um they didn't they didn't make those
decisions
they signed up they raised their right
hand all volunteers at a time of War to
say yeah put me in I'm gonna go fight
and some of them didn't make it back and
everybody that made it back made it back
a little bit different than when they
left and the president and the first
lady understand that and respect that
and they should know that they will
always have the commitment of the
commander achieve in the respect of the
country for doing that
um the report says uh the Trump
administration's four years of neglect
including a deliberate degradation that
Afghanistan operations in despair could
you be specific about deliberate
degradation what are you specifically
important to there are many aspects if
you look at the Doha agreement and what
led up into that um
when President Trump took office
there was more than ten thousand
American troops in Afghanistan he took
it down to 2500.
um he
negotiated the release of 5 000 Taliban
prisoners
that were being held by the ghani
government
um without
consultation with the ghani government
he negotiated the Doha agreement with
the Taliban without the gunny government
uh in the room
um and he all but froze the special
immigrant Visa program which had been
providing opportunities for some of our
Afghan allies to get out of the country
and to come and to come back
so it was a general sense of degradation
uh and the and neglect there uh that
that the president inherited and do not
underestimate the effect of that Doha
agreement had on the morale and the uh
uh
the willingness to fight on The Afghan
National Security and Defense Forces it
it had it had a very corrosive effect on
their willingness to continue to fight
for their country now we didn't see that
we didn't see that and part of the
reason we didn't see that is because we
couldn't see the plans the the previous
administration allegedly worked on
during the transition no as I said my
opening statement none of those plans
were forthcoming say that the
that you just listed especially what
those were some of the key ones and a
quick follow-up on what the report says
about the administration not
broadcasting loudly about any potential
worst case scenarios out of concern it
would signal lack of confidence in the
Afghan government's position we
obviously ended up seeing Connie flee
the country yeah um and so
was that a well thought out decision
what was was what a well thought out
decision his decision to flee not
broadcasting loudly
um any concerns about the lack of
confidence in the Afghan government yeah
look I think as I said it's a different
it's a difficult balance to strike and
um
uh we were having internal conversations
in fact we had conversations with the
ghani government about our concerns over
uh what was happening in the countryside
throughout Afghanistan there in early
August
um and uh and where we came down on was
not calling for uh an evacuation sooner
because we didn't want the ghani
government to collapse and we had every
Assurance made by President ghani and he
wasn't going anywhere that he was still
in charge that he still had a viable
Administration and so you know when do
you when do you make that call and it's
difficult it's tough to do it in the
moment and nobody can predict the future
again as I said we learned from that
experience and we applied a more
aggressive approach if you will in
Ethiopia and in Ukraine
but every instance is different every
every capital is that's under threat is
under a different kind of threat and you
have to evaluate it
that summer before the withdrawal there
was a descent a channel cable that was
written by a 23 State Department
officials there at the Kabul Embassy
warning that the administration in their
view was not prepared at that moment for
the withdrawal I'm curious did this
review take that descent cable into
account uh you'll have to talk to the
state department
the state department conducted an after
action review uh that and so did DOD and
that's a question better put to them and
then one specifically then for
um you know the president in this
Administration I'm curious if there was
a moment during the Afghanistan
withdrawal that the president lost
confidence in the assessments that were
given to him by the intelligence
community and lost confidence in the
intelligence Community itself given that
they failed to foresee uh how quickly
the Taliban would advance and Kabul
would fall the president knows how hard
people work across the administration uh
to try to give him uh the best
information that they can but it didn't
stop him from asking throughout the
entire withdrawal he was constantly
pulsing the National Security team about
this or that assessment and constantly
challenging the thinking constantly
looking for uh uh for ways to better
understand what was going on the ground
some of the assessments that that was
was produced as I put in my opening
statement proved out to be not correct
but uh but uh you know he again this was
you know an honest effort by everybody
to try to get at the right outcome that
they weren't working hard but their
assessment was flawed and they failed in
that assessment has anyone held
accountable for giving the president a
wrong View and how things were turning
out on the ground I don't know how much
intelligence you read or you get to look
at every day but let me tell you
something it's a mosaic it's really hard
um and I've yet to see
an intelligence assessment uh that uh
that ever was a hundred and ten percent
certain about something
um they they get paid to do the best
they can
weaving in multiple sources of
information sometimes in real time
without even a lot of time to process
and do and they do the best they can do
they always get it right they'll be the
first ones if they were up here to tell
you they don't always get it right and
clearly we didn't get things right here
with Afghanistan about how fast the
Taliban were moving across the country I
don't think we fully anticipated the
degree to which they were constructing
these deals in the Hinterlands that kind
of felt like dominoes we didn't
anticipate how fast the Afghan National
Security forces were gonna fold we're
not going to fight for their country
particularly after we had as I said
dedicated 20 years trained and equipped
them
um uh I don't think we have fully
appreciated the degree of corruption
that was in the officer ranks uh in the
military I could go on and on and on uh
but it doesn't mean that people weren't
trying and doing their best effort to
understand that but intelligence getting
it right every single time
man that's that's a tough that's a tough
Hill to climb doesn't mean that they
don't try okay
playing on the previous administration
starting with page one President Biden's
choices for how to execute withdrawal
from Afghanistan were severely
constrained by conditions created by his
predecessor yeah let me just follow up
with you on something that Ed was asking
which is does the president take
responsibility for the withdrawal in
everything that happened thereafter he's
the commander-in-chief
and uh he absolutely has responsibility
for uh the operations that our men and
women conduct and the orders that he
gives and he continues to believe that
the order to withdraw from Afghanistan
was the right one and if you just look
Kristen at what's happened since we
pulled out of Afghanistan and see what
the United States military has been
better able to do on behalf of the
American people I think there's only one
conclusion you can come to and that it
was the right decision and as you list
the things
but that but you need to remember and I
I get the question about you know the
previous administration you gotta look
at when he came into office what he was
walking into he didn't negotiate with
the Taliban he didn't invite the Taliban
to Camp David he didn't release 5 000
prisoners he didn't reduce Force levels
in Afghanistan to 2500 and he didn't
have an arrangement with the Taliban
that they won't attack our troops he
came in with a certain set of
circumstances he had no ability to
change he had to deal with it based on
what he inherited months to plan did he
not he had to take eight months to plan
because we whatever plans there might
have been done by the previous
administration we didn't see
um and and it was not apparent that that
there was a lot of planning done so yes
he took some time to uh to work through
that I don't think he could be blamed
for that in fact he enabled and was able
to secure from the Taliban extra time on
the clock because by May 1st you might
remember
they were going to come in guns Ablaze
and hang on a second I'll get to you uh
they were going to come in guns blazing
on May 1st he got us till the end of
August so that we could do I mentioned
that my opening statement proper
planning proper planning that that
accounted for high-risk scenarios and uh
and probabilities that we we hadn't
thought of before so that he could get
military forces pre-positioned in the
region so that if we had to go in and
conduct an evacuation they could do that
and you know how fast they got there 48
Hours when we ordered a Neo a
non-combatant evacuation because he put
them there and he had to have time to do
that what does the president believe
what mistakes does the president win he
made
I'm not going to speak for the uh
president on on that score what I can
tell you is uh that again we've done a
good faith effort here to work through
the Lessons Learned of this withdrawal
um and we've already started to apply
those lessons
the president ran a very inclusive
very rigorous very flexible process that
was responsive as I said to to uh to the
views of operational commanders on the
ground he repeatedly asked for and
received assessments almost every day
about what was going on
um and uh and acted in accordance with
the best Judgment of his advisors
particularly military advisors as things
were unfolding John finally given the
enormity of this report given the
American lives that were lost why are we
not hearing directly from the president
we are putting this forth for you and
for congress today uh and I think you've
heard from the president he has talked
many times about he has talked many
times about his decision to withdraw
from Afghanistan his belief that it was
the right decision he has taught
publicly about the withdrawal before uh
and about the courage and sacrifice and
the professionalism and he has been uh
he and the first lady have been very
open and honest and transparent about uh
about the sorrow that they feel for for
those that lost their lives
thanks John
who's gonna get fired over this
Peter the purpose of the document that
we're putting out today uh is to sort of
collate the chief reviews and findings
of the agencies that did after Action
reviews
um the it it's not the purpose of it is
not accountability it's the purpose of
it is military leaders purpose of it is
to study lessons that the intel was bad
so how can President Biden ever trust
when they come into the Oval Office with
the pdb that anything in there is legit
what I said was that intelligence is a
mosaic what if the Mosaic all the pieces
are incorrect what I said was
Intelligence is hard business and they
get it right a lot too there were some
pieces here that weren't accurate and
we're being nothing but honest with you
and the American people about what those
inaccuracies were and how they shaped
some of the decision making that was
laid before the president and his ques
and the questions that he that he asked
this document and this effort isn't
about accountability today it's about
understanding and I would also add that
the as I said the Ed the review process
isn't over this is this is the next
muscle movement in what will be a long
process to better understand and
comprehend and adjust to what we learned
and what we did in Afghanistan but it
doesn't seem like after the country has
had a couple months to review this and
as the government has
people don't have an issue with the
decision to order troops out of
Afghanistan it is with the way that this
President ordered it done there were
children being killed there were people
hanging off of Air Force jets that were
leaving and you're saying that you guys
are proud of the way that this mission
was conducted
it doesn't mean a bet
proud of the fact that we got more than
a hundred and twenty four thousand
people safely out of Afghanistan you bet
proud of the fact that American troops
were able to seize control of a defunct
airport and get it operational in 48
hours you bet proud of the fact that we
now have about a hundred thousand
Afghans our former allies and partners
living in this country and working
towards citizenship you bet does that
mean that everything went perfect in
that evacuation of course not I've
talked about it from a different Podium
the after Action reviews are now being
reviewed by members of Congress which
will lay out things that could have gone
better nobody's saying that everything
was perfect but there was a lot that
went right and a lot of Afghans are now
living better lives in this country and
other countries around the world because
of the sacrifices and the work of so
many American government officials so
yeah there's a lot to be proud of Peter
but thank you thanks John just to follow
up on my colleagues questioning about
the blame assigned to the previous
administration specifically how does the
how is the Trump Administration
responsible for the disorganized and
chaotic process of evacuation and
determining who gets to board these
evacuation flights uh I mean you
mentioned that there is there's a review
in terms of the Lessons Learned can you
share some of those Lessons Learned just
specifically in terms of who gets to
board evacuation flights I'm not going
to go beyond the review uh the document
that you have today or my comments uh
today
um but I'm actually glad for the
question uh
because I I remember going through all
that and those first few days were very
very tough they were very hectic because
we didn't have a forced Presence at
Karzai International Airport and we were
still in the process of taking those
pre-position forces and getting them
onto the field and we got them there
within 48 hours and about 72 hours after
that that airport was basically for all
intents and purposes American Property
surrounded by the Taliban and Isis K so
they not only had to run an airport get
The Radars up and go and do air traffic
control get planes coming in and getting
them loaded have medical screening have
security vetting have diplomatic
presence on the ground to make sure that
we're putting the right people on planes
but also defend that airport from
external threats
um that's pretty remarkable and so for
all this talk of chaos I just didn't see
it not from my perch at one point during
the evacuation there was an aircraft
taking off full of people Americans and
Afghans alike every 48 minutes and not
one single mission was missed so I'm
sorry I just won't buy the whole
argument of chaos it was tough in the
first few hours you would expect it to
be there was nobody at the airport
certainly no Americans it took time to
get in there is there anything in the
review that addresses the problem of who
was in charge at that time I think there
was a lot of analysis that questions
whether it should have been the military
who's in charge of the evacuation versus
the state department and that is partly
the problem of the confusion and I
understand your point about planes
leaving full of people
right and people falling off planes I
don't I actually don't accept the
premise of your question that there was
some sort of confusion over who runs it
was a non-combatant evacuation operation
once it was called and the military
leads those it's pretty clear now we
needed the support of the state
department because you had to have
diplomatic officers uh Consular officers
people trained and and uh in the in the
vetting of of individuals coming in we
needed that help for sure there was a
lot of interagency coordination and some
of it had to be developed in the moment
because we'd never done something like
this before but it was very clearly what
we call a Neo and non-combatant
evacuation operation which was led by
the military let me tell you something
else non-combatant evacuation operations
are the are probably some of the most
difficult not probably they are some of
the most difficult operations for any
military to conduct
the women's rights issue uh John says
here there since the withdrawal Afghan
women have suffered massively under the
Taliban and they have recently been
Afghan women from working as um staff
some believe that this is a tactic a
pressure tactic by the Taliban to secure
uh a seat at the U.N Afghanistan seat at
the U.N do you believe that this is a
tactic that will work under what
circumstances would the US even consider
allowing the Taliban have the
Afghanistan sea at the un uh again I
think we've talked about this I mean we
certainly
condemned this approach by the Taliban
it is uh and we're certainly not going
to be compliant with it
um if the Taliban
wants
International legitimacy in whatever
form
then they should
answer up to the commitments they made
in the Doha agreement and in other
agreements uh in this case to be
respectful of the rights of women and
girls and they haven't and uh so until
they do
they're going to be continuing to
struggle to gain some sort of sense of
legitimacy or assistance from the rest
of the world
Kareem thank you very much Admiral thank
you I have two questions about this
report first question is about the
intelligence angle I think we can safely
agree that anytime the assets of the
intelligence Community are harnessed to
an assessment of a life and death matter
and the community gets that wrong and
death ensues that that qualifies as an
intelligence failure
uh first question here is whether since
you have acknowledged essentially
without calling it as such an
intelligence failure in this case do we
know why
the intelligence communities got it
wrong what was it cultural was it
specific was it analytical what was the
problem with the intelligence Community
here the intelligence Community also
conducted after action uh reviews and
I'd let them speak to that I'm not going
to do that from here
second question
we in this room hear you saying and the
American people hear you saying
that President Biden inherited bad
policies from president Trump nope bad
outcomes bad conditions on the ground
that's what I said
reduce the force to 2500 you're
characterizing that as a bad policy yes
I'm characterizing that as a fact
okay what we hear you saying let me
finish my question please and what the
American people hear you saying is
President Biden inherited flawed
policies from his predecessor President
Biden was deprived of the requisite
transition papers he should have
received from his predecessor and
President Biden was deprived of accurate
information from president ghani about
his intentions and President Biden was
deprived of accurate assessments from
the intelligence community
the depiction of the commander-in-chief
that you present or this
commander-in-chief is of a figure almost
helpless and shaped and profited by
individuals and forces and entities that
are Beyond his control when he had every
option to increase the troop size there
during his eight months in office he had
every option to intensify attacks on the
5 000 Taliban fighters and so on so I
just don't understand why you're willing
to depict uh your boss the
commander-in-chief is so helpless in
this instance
president was anything but helpless he
drove a very as I said a a deliberate
and inclusive decision-making process
he was able to secure some extra time
for us to be able to conduct a
withdrawal and do so effectively he
repeatedly as I said in my opening
statement throughout the entire
withdrawal post his National Security
team and Senior military leaders about
the conditions on the ground asking
tough questions and getting answers and
getting responses and he acted on the
best military judgment and the best
assessments from the intelligence
Community as he could as he made these
decisions going forward and some of
those assessments turned out to be wrong
but it wasn't for a lack of alacrity and
energy and interest by the president in
pulsing and questioning and analyzing
all the way through and this was this
was difficult as I said at the very end
of my opening statement ending a war any
War is not an easy Endeavor certainly
not after 20 years and the president
said himself there was no way
in that process that it was going to be
low-grade low-cost low risk there was
going to be risks there were going to be
costs he knew that the team knew that
and everybody tried the best they could
to develop uh the best answers the best
responses the best assessments that they
could the president relied on that
judgment but he kept challenging it all
the way through he kept challenging it
he kept asking questions
your position is everything went about
as well as it possibly could have Mike
it's not my position James
encourage you to take
lessons learned that we took away are
that you've got to you've got to really
work hard at planning
you got to really work hard at internet
interagency coordination you gotta you
gotta be willing to uh to revisit uh the
idea of communications crisis
Communications with respect to
evacuations and maybe be willing to move
sooner than what some of your instincts
might be I mean there's a lot in there
so I encourage you to take a look at
that
these were independent reviews the after
action no no no
after Action reviews that were done by
the defense department and at the state
department they're the two prime ones
that we're talking about here uh they
were done completely independently you
you'll you'll see that well they're
still fundamentally his cabinet agencies
his cabinet leaders conducting the
agency or conducting the reviews of his
actions why not an outside commission
outside independent person to review
what the administration did each of
these agencies voluntarily
conducted these reviews the president
didn't dictate to them how they were
going to conduct those reviews they each
did it independently differently in a
different way but both state and state
state and DOD sorry uh did did their
reviews using independent entities
um and then that was pushed up to back
inside the lifelines at the state
department and the defense department
both secretary blinken and secretary
Austin had a chance to digest it look at
them review them analyze uh those
reviews and then of course we uh once
once once we did that those reviews
entered an interagency process where it
was looked that they were looked at in
conjunction here at the National
Security Council and across the
interagency by multiple agencies to take
a look at the work that the state
department and the defense department
did and fashioned together some even
broader Lessons Learned some of which we
shared in that document that we gave you
and I know you were asked earlier about
releasing more beyond the beyond the
12th page report word I mean you talked
about information just being very highly
classified but the president can
obviously declassify anything that he
wants so would he do so in the interest
of transparency in the interest of the
public knowing more about what happened
what they withdrawal beyond the 12-page
perspective of the NSC so again a couple
of things to remember that this is an on
ongoing process here we also look
forward to cooperating with the Afghan
war commission which we'll take a look
at the 20 years of war these documents
are sensitive and classified we are
taking an extraordinary step here to
share them with members of Congress the
relevant committees and leaders usually
with after actions there's no
requirement to do that you don't have to
do that but the president has taken that
extraordinary step to share these
classified uh aars these after Action
reviews with with members of Congress
and we believe that the real value in
them lies in the fact that we can be
sensitive we can be sensitive to the
information in them and so that's why
that's why we're doing it this way
thanks you
you I just don't how is this process and
document not about accountability you
assign so much accountability to the
Trump Administration and very little
comparatively to your own after Action
reviews are done uh to as very common
practice they are not investigations
they're not uh they're not criminal
proceedings they are
proceedings they are studying they are
studying uh the the conduct and the
execution uh of operations or policy uh
and in this case both state and DOD have
now conducted these in a classified way
the idea is to learn from them uh to uh
to apply those Lessons Learned as needed
and as I've said we didn't wait for
these reviews to be complete before we
started using some of the lessons in
Ethiopia uh in Ukraine that's the
purpose here the the work is about
understanding what happened what uh what
went well what could have gone better
and then learning from that so that we
don't make some of those same mistakes
in the future that's what it is it's not
it's not hunting for heads
[Music]
the second one
um you said the president earlier
somebody asked if the president takes
responsibility for this withdrawal and
what happened after you answered and
said he has responsibility does he take
responsibility and have you heard him
say that the president is the
commander-in-chief
um and just by denta being the
he assumes responsibility for the orders
he gives the men and women who execute
those operations in this case it's not
just the military
um and uh and he stands by that
China has increased its economic ties
with Taliban the first signing oil deal
in January and now I mineral contract is
the White House concerned about these
growing economic ties between China and
Taliban and can you share some comments
about it
we uh look our view every country's got
to take their own view here of how
they're going to
relate to the Taliban uh we aren't we
don't recognize them as an official
government in Afghanistan
um and as I said before if they want to
be so recognized at least by the United
States if they want to be seen as
legitimate then they need to own up to
the promises they made about how they
were going to govern that country and
how they were going to treat their own
people including women and girls
accountability I I appreciate the fact
that lessons have been learned
I assume that the president still has
full confidence in his National Security
team it gave him the advice which is
pointed out in the summary why should
the American people have confidence in
all of those National Security advisors
given
what what this report lays up
the president does have trust and
confidence in his National Security team
uh and he did ask a lot of questions
and
and there was some assessments passed to
him that that proved faulty that proved
to be wrong that proved to to not
uh shake out the way uh he had been
given to understand that they would
but in the aggregate as he looks across
all the work that the National Security
team continues to do before and since
the withdrawal from Afghanistan
he has continues to conclude that this
is an extraordinary extraordinarily
talented group of leaders and
as as uh
you know as I said in my opening
statement uh as painful at times as a
withdrawal was
it wasn't without its moments of courage
and Poise and it it it doesn't mean that
it wasn't worth doing ending that war in
Afghanistan because if you just take a
look at what we've been able to do for
Ukraine and how we've been able to
really step up in the competition
against China and deal with some of the
tensions in the indo-pacific it's
difficult to say that we would have been
able to do all that we did over the last
year so without if we were still dragged
down on the ground in Afghanistan in
fact
Putin and she probably would like
nothing better than for us to still be
bogged down in a ground war in
Afghanistan sorry if I could just follow
up Kristen asked a question earlier this
report is the summary of your
perspectives came out as the president
was on his way to the camp David Retreat
for the Easter weekend when should we
anticipate an opportunity for the
president to stand for our questions
about the findings and stuff I don't
have anything on this schedule to speak
to
two questions one will be on a different
topic I'll start with that one the
president's sleeping for Northern
Ireland uh fairly soon yeah are there
any plans for him to meet with
representatives of uh Shin Fein and the
dup uh to try to resolve the impasse
that's kept a functioning developed
government for being in place yeah I
tell you we're going to have as Kareem
said at the top we'll have more to talk
about in terms of specific agenda items
on Monday before we leave okay and on on
Afghanistan this document says there
were there was no such plans uh for
withdrawal in place when President Biden
came into office uh no plans were shared
during the transition
were there any attempts to speak with uh
former Trump officials about whether
there were plans and does the lack of of
plans in place indicate that they
deliberately uh they deliberately
sabotaged the incoming Administration by
by not continuing to plan dropping
plants at one place or they might have
been working on or did is there a
possibility that they didn't intend on
following through with the agreement
that the former president made to be out
by Mac I can't speak for leaders in the
previous administration and I I I
certainly can't speak for whatever plans
they did or did not draw up I can tell
you with confidence that the transition
team of the incoming Administration
asked repeatedly to see plans for
withdrawal for Retrograde as we say it
in the military uh for the special
immigrant Visa program for the turnover
of equipment and and bases to the Afghan
National Security Defense Forces and as
I said in my opening statement none more
forthcoming it wasn't for lack of trying
they weren't they weren't sharing and so
one of the reasons why to Kristen's
earlier question about the length of
time that it took to conduct a review
was because we were almost starting from
scratch there was no there was no
visibility into what they had done in
fact we spent quite a bit of time after
coming into office and I remember this
quite clearly trying to get our hands
around the Doha agreement and really
understanding
all its articles and and what it meant
and how it was being interpreted by the
Taliban there just wasn't any of that
fingertip field or Gran or granular
awareness that we had
the city Administration can access
documents from the prior Administration
was there any attempt to find out if if
they even started to play what was there
ever multiple attempts to try to gain
insight as to into what the previous uh
bless you what the previous team had
been doing and as I said earlier and as
is indicated in that document none of
those plans were forthcoming all right
it's been about an hour guys
John I have two occasions on South Korea
and China
at the summit meeting between President
Biden and South Korean president
this month what agenda are you going to
be uh discussed this week
uh you're way ahead of me today Janie uh
I I don't have any agenda items to talk
about uh today but certainly in due
course we will
please uh do you yes do you is
integrated the country's strategy
includes a new policy toward the China
what tours can the United States use for
China to have
North Korea's missile and nuclear
propagation we know that China has
influence in Pyongyang and we have long
urged them to use that influence to get
Mr uh to get Mr Kim to do the right
thing and to be willing to sit down with
us as we have said we are without
preconditions to uh to diplomatically
try to deal with a denuclearization of
the peninsula okay
spending a lot of time answering our
questions I have a question what message
do you have for the people around the
world
who don't look
Administration made mistakes or failed
but lost some confidence in the United
States ability to deal with such
difficult situations as in Afghanistan
I would encourage them to look at what
we have been able to achieve in the two
plus years of this Administration across
the board
and as I said even in Afghanistan
because ending that war was the right
thing to do for this country and our
national security interests we are on a
stronger strategic footing we are better
able to deal with the most pressing
challenges of the day which are not
quite by the way emanating out of
Afghanistan certainly not anymore
because we are no longer in Afghanistan
and take a look at the incredible
leadership of the United States in
support for Ukraine take a look at the
NATO alliance which now just got a new
member take a look at the strengthening
of alliances and Partnerships in the
indo-pacific the new August deal with
Australia and the UK and the ability for
them to the Australians now to get a
nuclear power submarine I could go on
and on and on the president has
prioritized alliances and Partnerships
many of whom were left left in the wake
of the previous administration and
denigrated were revitalized advising
them or bringing them back we're
reinforcing them and America's footing
on the global stage is a lot stronger
now
thank you thank you thank you John
um so one on this and one on China if I
could uh and look you through this it
doesn't seem to address the seven
billion dollars in military hardware and
technology that was left in Afghanistan
for the Taliban you know the president
took office in January the which all
happened in August does the president
take responsibility for for leaving all
or some of that you know who's
responsible for that equipment
the Afghans because you know why it was
their equipment first of all I don't
believe the numbers accurate but let's
put the number aside the seven million
seven million dollars
um there was very little and I mean very
little U.S owned equipment or U.S
operating equipment that we left when we
left Afghanistan I'm talking like
some forklifts at the airport
um and some ladder Vehicles some fire
trucks uh that we were using at the
airport but the and the helicopters that
we left there all disabled so the
Taliban couldn't get them flying again
whatever ground Vehicles like uh mraps
or Humvees they were all disabled at the
airport everything else
outside of that airport the stuff that's
at Bagram or you pick the base in
Afghanistan was all turned over in
according with a very elaborate
deliberate retrograde plan that the U.S
military put in place to turn over all
that stuff to the Afghan military and
the Afghan military as I said in my
opening statement decided they weren't
going to fight for their country that
they were just going to leave it behind
so it is the Afghans who were
responsible for the turnover of all that
equipment
quickly um so you can run down a list of
how China is helping Russia Russia
became China's largest importer of oil
at the beginning of this year China has
moved its credit card in to help Russia
transactions
um you know China's made a deal now with
Saudi Arabia for oil transactions uh
they're making a deal they're working
with Brazil to move off the U.S dollar
you know at what point does the
president stand up and more loudly tell
China to a cut it out or be counter some
of China's anti-us I know we're in a
strategic competition with China and we
have made it clear to Chinese officials
that we don't think this is a time for
anybody to be supporting in one of the
cases you had Mr Putin's ability to
profit alpha alpha oil on the market so
that he can continue to kill more
ukrainians one of the reasons why the
president sat down with President XI and
Bali was to deliver some of those
messages
we we believe it is a competition and we
believe the United States is well poised
to win that competition we don't seek
conflict with China but we are not at
all unabashed or we are we are unabashed
and unafraid uh to make it clear to the
Chinese that we're going to do what we
have to do to protect our national
security interests and again this is no
time to be in partnership with Vladimir
Putin
yeah thanks um and we'll just one to
clarify what Dave was asking about after
January 20th 2021
there was no ability to find plans for
withdrawal and orderly withdrawal is
that what I'm inferring what you said
about
the previous administration's plans once
you come in you do the best you can to
because now you own things you can you
can look and see what what was done and
you can study it
is there anything done after not talking
about the transition but after you came
into almost one example I can give you
for sure is that one of the early trips
uh of 2021 that secretary Austin made
was to Kabul and he sat down there with
the isaf commander General Miller and
and general Miller walked him through uh
some of the retrograde plans that he had
already formed up
um and uh you know in that and that
acted as a basis for uh what we
eventually executed on but it doesn't
mean that we didn't
order or look for amendments and changes
and that kind of thing that's one
example I can't speak about every agency
and what plans they may or may not have
fallen in on the problem is there was no
visibility on that in the transition you
have a very brief period of time between
election night and inauguration and
Afghanistan was one of the chief foreign
policy concerns the president had coming
in and the team desperately wanted to
understand the Doha agreement wanted to
talk to experts wanted to talk to
planners wanted to see what had been
done because the president had already
made a commitment that he wanted to end
that war but he wanted to do it
responsibly we couldn't find out exactly
what the previous administration had
done on paper and that's difficult so
you say okay well January 20th it's all
available to you but he shouldn't have
had to wait until January 20th to get
access to that it would have been better
wouldn't it I think for everybody if we
could come in you know with deck running
there uh right on the right on twice on
on the uh the former president is now
then saying several times that number
one China is actually running background
now and it was 85 billion in brand new
equipment equipment better than we
actually have can you address that
please I don't get the last claim what
I'm just asking I don't I can't I I
can't address I don't understand it I
don't look I don't go back to the answer
before it's important because this is
getting well misunderstood out there
there was a retrograde plan working
towards withdrawal where bases that we
were operating out of and equipment that
we had that we believe the Afghans could
and should keep were turned over to them
in a very thoughtful orderly way all the
way from Spring well Into Summer
Once you turn it over it's just like
what we're doing in Ukraine we give
Ukraine uh artillery ammunition Stinger
anti-air missiles Javelin anti-tech it's
their stuff at that point not the
Americans it's their stuff that stuff
belonged to the Afghans and so this idea
this argument is just ludicrous that we
left millions of dollars of stuff in
Afghanistan we didn't we turned it over
as the previous administration would
have done too because part of their
thinking was they were going to have to
turn this material over it was turned
over appropriately and carefully and
deliberately with the Afghan National
Security Defense Forces
do you have any insight into why the
Russians are refusing him Consular
access and do you have any updates on
efforts I wish we did I wish we did
Sabrina we uh we still haven't been able
to get console access
um and that's a that's an issue that we
continually bring up uh through our our
Embassy in Moscow with the Russians I
wish I had a good answer for that
because it's inexcusable we need to get
console access to Evan at what point
would the administration explore a
potential prisoner swap with Russia I
won't get ahead of where we are and I
think you can understand why we would
certainly want to talk about potential
negotiations here from the podium we're
at a very early stage here main goal is
to get Consular access to them so we can
have that contact and that connectivity
uh we're uh and doing what we can to
keep his employer and a family informed
our focus is squarely on that right now
really quickly on Afghanistan and that
Israel when did President Biden get the
after action report and has a right
through the entire the president has
been fully briefed on both after action
reports and he certainly uh uh has been
briefed
um and uh and and had input on the
document that that you see before you uh
today uh so and then on the when I would
tell you that to Ed's question and this
is a process and he has stayed in touch
with the state department and the
defense department as they have worked
through their after Action reviews and
then are there plans to release each of
the apartments reports to their
respective workforces I mean there's
people who worked on this withdrawal who
want to learn these are classified
reports I do not anticipate any any
release of them publicly or uh on a more
broad fashion but that's a better
question put to the agencies and then on
the situation in Israel how can started
as the White House if this could
escalate into a greater situation
yeah we're very concerned about the
violence there we see now it increased
more attacks in the last 24 hours uh
we're deeply concerned about that we
call on all sides to de-escalate reduce
the violence
thanks um in February 2022 the Pentagon
about the Pentagon pardon me Abby gate
uh bombing gave a very detailed minute
by minute account very graphic nature of
what happened why not do something more
like that about this that was very
public why not give more details about
what happened leading up to Afghanistan
as well uh as the withdrawal as well as
all the chaos that happening you're
talking about
an event on a single day that uh that
the military investigated and reviewed
the investigation of and yes they made
they made public uh not everything about
that investigation but as much as they
possibly could that's different than
taking a look at a withdrawal that took
place over two weeks and involved
multiple agencies and again I remind you
that these agencies voluntarily decided
on their own uh to to do these after
Action reviews with the president's
course full support because he wanted to
know as well uh and um the result coming
back are sensitive classified documents
and there's no obligation uh to to even
share those with members of Congress but
we're doing that Jeremy jig Sullivan
promised a hot wash I think it's the
words he used to to describe what would
come out of that that certainly sounded
like a very detailed accounting and you
say this is not about accountability uh
but how does the American people
um trust that the United States has
learned from the mistakes that were made
if they do not see those mistakes and
see the administration acknowledging
them being public with them and how
they're going to address them I think
that's what I'm doing today and I think
that's the document you got in front of
you I think it also hang on a second
it's also the fact that those after
Action reviews are on Capitol Hill
voluntarily so that uh relevant
committees and relevant senior members
of Congress can look at them they are
sensitive and they are classified and we
also have a responsibility of the
American people to protect some
information so that it doesn't get out
there so that we can continue to apply
some of those lessons in future
operations the last thing I'll say to
your question is there's an Afghan war
commission that's been legislated the
president signed that legislation it
will look at the whole war and that will
have a very public Dimension to it and
this Administration and every agency in
it will actively and uh and uh
uh and uh with uh with appropriate
energy participate in that
um
and then you said we'll have more on the
trip but I had a quick question we have
to start the UK
rain talks
talk us uh the Prime Minister sunac does
the US have any interest in restarting
trade talks with the UK and the Will
President Biden meet with the Prime
Minister when he's in Northern Ireland I
haven't seen that report until I'd
rather not comment on that right now uh
but and as for the agenda uh I think you
just got to give us till Monday we'll
have much more detail on the agenda who
he's meeting with and under what context
on Monday the pre-twake free trade
questions
at the administration's position change
you've all seem pretty cool to the idea
I understand I have nothing for you
Christians in Ukraine thank you John
according to the financial times the
high-ranking advisor of President
Selinsky signaled that it might not be
longer a precondition to get to Premiere
back
um to start negotiations is that the
development the White House got the plot
uh first of all I don't know that the
zielinski Administration has spoken to
that and we certainly wouldn't get ahead
of them what I would tell you is and
we've said this from the very beginning
that only president zielinski can
determine if and when he's ready to
negotiate and in what context and over
what we believe
that nothing should be negotiated about
Ukraine without Ukraine nothing should
be done or said or moved on without
president zielinski's full approval
that's where we are
now where ascensions are fair enough
again that's for sure Taiwan
um with warships being deployed Etc can
you update us of what channels of
communication are currently open between
the administration in China is that a
functional military channel in case of
tensions arising uh what's the state of
communication between the communication
with China remain open we have
communicated
to China privately we've certainly done
it publicly here with you all that
there's no reason for them to overreact
to this Transit it's uh not uncommon for
for these transits to happen they're
private they're unofficial we would urge
China not to overreact
first and benefits end later this summer
what's going to happen to them
I think I'd have to let me take that
question uh and but I'll also while I do
that I'm going to refer you to the state
department they'll have more details on
that um and a second question
um there were there was reporting about
cities to the agreement on the peace
agreement uh that contributed to the
Afghan offenses in 2021 uh did the Biden
administration review those annexes on
what did they contain um
once we I'm not going to talk about what
they can contain but
will be stuck I'm not going to talk
about things that are classified uh but
we had an opportunity after coming into
office to review in more detail the Doha
agreement and all the associated
articles and pieces of it and I would
just go back to what I said before that
I think
it would be difficult
to overstate the impact of that Doha
agreement on the afghan's willingness to
trust us
on their willingness to stay and fight
for their country
um and on the general morale of the
Afghan people once the deal you know
became publicly known it was a clear
sign that America was heading for the
exits and doing so in a hurry and it had
a dramatic effect on The Afghan National
Security Forces thanks thank you you
said that this on the withdrawal you
said that this was just one step this
report in a better understanding uh
better comprehending the withdrawal and
the adjustments made accordingly
afterwards are there any additional
steps that you guys are taking is this
the absolute final report no there's an
Afghan war Commission
in addition or any additional final
report
aside from this that we can expect to
see these are the after action reports
of the agencies that were most heavily
involved in the withdrawal I know of no
additional after Action reviews that are
being done or or planned to being done
again they were fed into a larger
Administration process that the National
Security Council worked to sort of
coalesce these Lessons Learned and the
result of that extra work by the uh by
the interagency is what you see before
you today
one more on a separate matter uh state
department secretary blinken said that
uh he has no doubt that Evan gurskovich
was wrongfully detained uh related to
that Mark fogle's sister told NewsHour
last night that her family is angered by
what they consider quote favoritism by
the administration vogel's sister told
us that the family has not heard from
President Biden or secretary blinken so
when will Pogo be designated as
wrongfully detained and are there any
ongoing conversations I can't speak to
that from that from here in the state
department would have to deal with that
they're the ones that make
determinations about wrongful detention
I would remind that each determination
is done in an individual case
case-by-case basis
thank you about the document just to
clarify it says and I quote National
Security leaders met on August 9 and
concluded conditions on the ground did
not did not support triggering the
evacuation operation then it says that
in August 14th President Biden formally
initiated this operation can you explain
to us what happened between between
those two dates in between those two
assessments many things happen
um in that you know in that five days I
don't have all my notes in front of me
from then but we continue to see
uh particularly over that week the
Taliban uh achieving more and more
success in the hinterland particularly
out west into the north taking over
District by District Province by
province uh and so there was a sort of
rolling momentum that they had and the
danger to Kabul uh got more acute over
the course of that four or five days and
and again you know as I said earlier uh
first of all non-combatant evacuations
are some of the most difficult
operations and choosing when you're
going to go there and that's a state
department gets to call that but the
military executes and leads it and
finding that exact moment to do it is is
it can be difficult particularly when
you're dealing with a government who you
obviously we wanted to see succeed
wanted to see stay in power and so uh
you gotta be careful about when you go
ahead and call for a Neo so that you're
not undermining the very outcome you're
trying to to uh to keep in persistence
about China by me recently in a
congressional Hearing in house foreign
congresswoman from Florida said that
countries in Latin America such as
Venezuela and Bolivia are allowing China
to gain football in the region so how
would you characterize this Chinese
presence in Latin America and how big is
it a security challenge for the United
States just in general we see the
Chinese continue to try to gain
influence in Latin America but also in
Africa and they do this in a pretty
ham-fisted way with uh with with high
interest loans that that some countries
then end up can't you know not not being
able to pay back and then suffer the
consequences to their own economic
growth and development for that
um I you know we're not asking countries
to choose between the United States and
China or the western China but we do
think it's important for them to
understand that in accepting Chinese
help that the
eventually putting their own economic
livelihoods at greater risk last
question
so my holy time for all abrahamic faiths
right now
you say you're concerned is that it I
mean this is some of these people were
worshiping and some of them were even
sleeping when they were attacked isn't
this time to condemn yeah
well yes I said we're concerned that
what we have in the previous few days
condemned use that verb we have condemn
that violence of course we have and
you're right people should be able to to
worship freely and safely and we still
stand by the status quo on the temple
Mountain uh uh that that has not changed
our policies have not changed we
urgently urge both all sides to reduce
this violence all side situation I mean
right now this was Israeli forces
attacking Muslim worshipers during
Ramadan we urge all sides to de-escalate
and to reduce the violence mean then
this is the White House taking sides the
fact that you're not willing to single
out the Israeli forces
were taking on is is uh Safety and
Security the side we're taking on is the
status quo the side that we're taking is
one of peaceful worship that's the side
we're taking thanks everybody
all right thank you so much Admiral over
an hour
um
okay uh I guess if you guys still want
to stick around I'll take a couple more
questions or not if not we can we can
wrap this up right here and I'll see you
guys on Monday
all right okay go swimming just kick
this off yes I just have one um there
was a report and it was like yes I have
a question so we can take a couple
questions well there's a report in
propublica this morning that talked
about Justice cards Thomas taking all of
these uh luxury trips from a republican
Mega donor
um appearing not to disclose those gifts
as required by law so does the White
House believe that this is a violation
of ethical standards that a Justice
should be held to and does the president
want a more rigorous code of conduct for
Supreme Court Justices I'm not going to
comment from here are there other bodies
of government that should be dealing
with this I'm just not going to comment
from here
you got this Ireland trip next week
The Dramatics
a trip to Ireland
countertime
or end the war in Ukraine so let me just
say a couple of things the president is
certainly looking forward uh to taking
this trip to Northern Ireland and also
the UK where he'll be heading out on
Tuesday we certainly will have more to
share on this trip uh uh coming in the
upcoming days as my colleague just said
on Monday but I I also want to lay out
here the important uh kind of the
important history between U.S and
Ireland right when you think about the
waves of Irish immigrants who help who
help shape America's Spirit of Freedom
that's incredibly important as well and
I think telling that story the president
going there and being able to touch on
his own his own family story The and the
stories of many of Americans here Azure
Americans here as you think about how
this country was created and built and
put together by immigrants I think
that's important I think that's
something that's important to highlight
and the person's the president looking
forward to that
oh
occurring any update on the debt limit
talks is there are there any plans
underway and I know we ask you this I
don't know for President Biden to meet
with or speak with
honestly when it comes to asking me
about what are the plans I would ask the
Republicans in the house uh it is it is
their you know constitutional Duty as we
have said over and over again in the
last three times in the last
Administration Democrats met with and
joined Republicans to get this done to
get something that is so critical to the
American people to taxpayers uh to
Veterans to seniors and so that's
actually a question for House
Republicans to answer
so critical Korean why are you letting
the clock it's closer to this yeah I'm
going to be very clear I I just
definitely disagree with uh with with
the question Kristen here because it is
not us it is them the onus is on
Congress to get this done this is their
responsibility their constitutional
responsibility to get this done
Republicans in the house cannot and
should not be holding uh you know our
nation's debt uh hostage they should not
be doing that we've been very very clear
they did it three times three times in
the last Administration
that the U.S won't default default I
that is for House Republicans to answer
that truly is for them to uh to deal
with this situation that we have said
again it is their responsibility their
constitutional responsibility I can't
say that enough they should be done
without negotiations this should be done
without conditions and it has been done
many times before uh and uh and they
should just take this seriously okay I
know we all have to write stories but I
just want to ask you there's so many
people in the country have been talking
about it this came up in yesterday's
briefing LSU says that the team
certainly will come but I wanted to give
you an opportunity to address some of
the emotions that have been aired by
some of the players a particular Angel
Reese and what she said this week is is
that she were on the other foot if Iowa
had won the first lady wouldn't have
said
unless you come can you respond to that
look first of all as you know the
president uh put out put out a statement
days ago saying how he and the first
lady are welcome and looking forward to
celebrating uh to celebrating LSU Tigers
and the University of Connecticut
clearly the men's team the Huskies and
that is something that is tradition here
continuing that tradition from here and
celebrating the Champions and that is
something that both of them are looking
forward to look the first lady was
honored to attend the championship game
as we know it was a historic game 9.9
million people watched that game it was
uh the LSU Tigers that win was historic
it set a record and we could not be more
proud of them again a great game and a
wonderful moment for women's sports in
history something both the first lady
and as you know the president have
talked about they feel very passionate
about that and it was truly a remarkable
and important moment and again the first
lady was honored to be part of that and
so I will say as I've said yesterday and
I'll say again she and the president are
truly looking forward to welcoming LSU
LSU Tigers here to celebrate them to
celebrate them as Championship Champions
to celebrate their history Victory and
uh and we're looking forward to
welcoming another so I'll just leave it
there go ahead Josh
the debt ceiling issue this is a plan
reportedly coming together
to get problem solvers caucus on some
sort of strategy to raise the debt
ceiling is why does involved in those
talks at all and are you open to those
sorts of plans or do you need a budget
from a car piece
so I'll touch on on both look we haven't
spoken to the problem solvers about that
we've made our position very clear you
heard me go back and forth with Kristen
here the debt ceiling and our economy
should not be held hostage we've been
very clear about that Republican threats
of chaos and
catastrophic potential outcome that's
not going to work that is not what uh
should that is not what they should be
doing as their constitutional Duty so
we've been very clear on that as far as
the budget the president put out his
Budget on March 9th we have been very
clear about that if they want to have a
conversation about the budget if they
want to show the American people what
they value what they think their fiscal
responsibility is we're happy to have
that conversation we're happy to have to
sit down the president would love to sit
down and negotiate and talk through that
but we haven't they haven't been able to
do that all they do is present uh you
know excuses that's what we've been
seeing so the budget will have a
negotiation on that if they present
something they haven't done that yet the
debt ceiling it should be done with out
negotiation it should be done without
conditions very quickly on our favorite
topic that the advice true I'm very
interested remember caring about the
vice chair I'm the fed and the vice
chair act that's surprising to me today
is six weeks since you said it would be
announced in the near future uh what
changed or what's the status it is uh
definitely a priority for the president
I I know I we understand how important
this is clearly and so uh once we have a
decision that is made by the president
certainly we will be sharing that I just
don't have anything to share at this
time
don't have
such a we are going to follow the
process that we always do when we uh
when we nominate critical candidates
important candidates we do this in in a
way that's uh clearly looking at
qualified diverse candidates but I'm
just not going to get into specifics on
on his particular question or or uh or
ask I should say all right
I know you don't want to comment on the
plans Thomas report specifically but
broadly do you think the White House
um broadly do you think the Supreme
Court uh my dad means to impose ethics
rules that lower federal courts are
subjected to that's something for the
Supreme Court to speak to I'm just not
going to comment on this at this time do
you think Congress needs to act that
that is something for Congress to uh to
discuss I'm just not going to comment on
this at this time all right I'll take
I'll take one uh
hi thank you so much so um we've just
seen the accession of Sweden and Finland
to Nato we're three months away from the
NATO leader Summit in July president
zolinski and some Eastern member states
Eastern member states are would like to
see Ukraine presented with a path to
citizenship uh to Nato membership uh is
the US is President Biden opposed to
that idea and what causes the
administration's hesitation is it if if
there if that exists is it a fear of
provoking Russia or is it apprehension
that U.S troops would have to deploy if
Ukraine joins you joins NATO before
Russia leaves so we've spoken to this a
couple of times look the our position is
pretty clear when it when it comes to a
NATO uh a session and uh you know for
decades we support an open door policy
for NATO any decision on membership is
between NATO allies and countries
assigned to join NATO and right now
we're we're focused on supporting
Ukraine's efforts and we're focusing on
making sure that the Ukrainian people
have what they need to fight for their
freedom and so you've seen us do that
you've seen us announce uh security
assistance for Ukraine this past year we
have been leading in that effort we have
been also uh really uh holding NATO
together holding the West making sure
that they are aligned and you've seen
that throughout throughout this year and
so we're going to continue to make sure
that they have the economic and security
assistance needed to fight a very uh to
fight continue to fight bravely uh this
uh this aggression from Russia that we
have seen for over a year now but again
this is something for uh between NATO
allies and NATO countries uh to decide
the U.S is a NATO Ally and has been
they have a lot of say over whether
Ukraine will be presented with this time
it's a possible membership what is the
US's position again been very clear for
decades for decades we have been pretty
consistent on this we support an open
door policy for NATO uh and uh I'm just
going to leave it there it's been it's
been like this for decades now all right
yeah okay I'm getting I'm getting the
the pool here all right I'll see you
guys on Monday have a great weekend and
happy Easter